[Music]
[Applause]
Jim Harbaugh interviewed with the
Chargers yesterday interviewed with the
Atlanta Falcons while negotiating a new
contract extension with Michigan Dan
Wetzel Yahoo sports columnist New York
Times bestselling author had some nice
juicy details about this with what Jim
Harbaugh is trying to put in his
contract the language good morning Dan
Enlighten our audience on what Harbaugh
is trying to put in this new contract
extension well I think look if he gets
offered the right job in the NFL he's
going to go to the NFL I think that's a
fair uh expectation so this is really a
backup plan I'm not really sure there's
anything Michigan could do uh other than
some absurd Financial amount or
something um that could keep Jim
Harbaugh if he finds the Intriguing
offer
but there's certainly the backup plan so
it's you know six years $1.5 million
guaranteed base with some performance
bonuses that would make him either
certainly the highest paid in the Big 10
um perhaps in the uh the whole country
some of these new deals uh we're not
sure all the details
um there are are certain Clauses that
are are unusual uh he can't he basically
can't gets immunity from punishment for
either of the two current NCA
investigations that are going on one
into whether he misled investigators who
are looking into a bunch of uh level two
violations and then of course the Connor
stallion situation with the advanced
scouting and the and the sign stealing
uh there would be a a set deal that uh
in future violations there'd be kind of
a matrix defined if anything else comes
up a series of fines um really laying
out some different things that could
happen uh in the future uh he's trying
to not execute this deal even if he were
to agree to an extension right now it
wouldn't go into place until February 15
uh which is is pretty smart because
right now his buyout if a if a team
wants to hire him away from Michigan
they owe Michigan $1.5 million that
dropped on January 11th uh the New Deal
would maybe be about $4 million but if
it it's not executed until February 15th
then that would pretty much be the
entire NFL cycle uh coaching Carousel
cycle so you know he would still be on
the lower deal um different ways that he
could potentially be terminated and he's
trying to get everything in there that
he possibly can it's a really unique
situation because rarely do we have uh a
coach win a National Championship also
be under two NCA violation cases and
have all this NFL interest at the same
time so as with everything with Jim
Harbaugh it is its own unique contract
uh job search uh situation but I think
Bill self has similar language in his
contracted Kansas he does and uh that
might be the the the path here Bill self
wasn't about to leave for the NBA while
he was working that out though but Bill
self is essentially unfireable uh and it
gets to where if you if you're going to
fire Harbaugh for cause it would it
would go to like a three it wouldn't be
the ad who could do it it would be a
three panel uh arbitration kind stuff
they do with presidents of universities
uh it's pretty creative to get as much
protection for Jim uh as you possibly
can going forward and uh a quick aside
the NCA has got a new system in place
called strict liability for head coaches
so that if anybody on your staff any
assistant coach any staffer violates an
NCA rule the head coach is now
responsible and uh I think what Jim is
trying to do here and I think it's going
to become common place for all coaches
is that may be true for the NCA but I
can't be fired for that um I can't
normally if there's an NCA violation the
language would say you're that is caused
for termination I think what all these
coaches are going to say is that's not
fair there's a hundred people working in
this football office there's 25 working
in this basket if if somebody does
something somewhere I can't lose my $10
million year job so he's a little
Cutting Edge on that one that the uh the
coaches aren't aren't too in favor of
this new NCA standard of punishment if
Jim Harbaugh goes to the NFL is he
obligated to talk to the NCAA with the
investigation into uh Michigan's
sanctions he is not so once you're not
an NCA coach you are free free to walk
away and uh they mercifully do not have
uh the power to compel testimony I don't
think we need that out of NCA
investigators is it Harbaugh wants to go
to the N I'm trying to figure out if I'm
Michigan in this situation I like at
what point do you say we're going to
move on here can they move on from Jim
Harbaugh before Jim Harbaugh moves on
from
them uh you know he's uh 40 and three in
the last three years just won the naal
title yeah but they won six games
without him on the sideline they did but
uh it was their they've won they won
half a they they won half a national
title in 1997 and the one before that
was
1948 so Jim Harbaugh has a tremendous
amount of support certainly amongst the
fans and boosters uh and the school they
want to keep him but I I agree with you
I I think there's only so much you can
do and look if you want to go to the
Chargers go to the Chargers and look
there are there's seven jobs open now we
could still get Dallas we could still
get Philly probably not Pittsburgh we're
hearing now but you don't know we're
starting to get into real franchise this
isn't like do you want to go to Carolina
and lose and get fired in two years uh
these are real opportunities he's
already interviewed at two spots so I
kind of feel like if Jim Harbaugh can't
get a NFL job this year it's not going
to happen and and if I you know if
you're Michigan you're kind of like look
we'll pay you we'll give you some stuff
we'll we'll protect you we've been
behind you all the way but to just walk
away from them they're not ready to do
that and and uh um you know that's just
the that's just the situation he's 15-0
does a lot for uh for your juice on
campus what if you could place Jim
Harbaugh in the NFL knowing his
personality uh where would you place him
um I you know I think I I I don't know
that his his personality um I don't
think it necessarily
matters where I think he has to have a a
an owner that understands that he's not
going to operate maybe quite like
somebody else but guy's are a remarkable
football coach so I would just want him
at a ready-made winner I think you know
if you could plug him in and he can
create uh the culture and the staff
Dallas but like Dallas with with I don't
know Dallas is a great idea you know I
think I think the Chargers would be
great there's not going to be a lot of
media tension and all that put him in
the middle of the circus and it's he's
going to become part of the circus if
you keep him kind of just uh coaching
football I think one of Harbaugh's
issues at Michigan and the reason
there's violation cases stuff he's
not from the outside looking in and my
guess and knowing people he's not a
manager 100 people he's a football coach
and he needs to coach football not you
know not well what is this assistant
doing am I on top of this staffer what's
this guy up to that's not him he needs
to coach football and be focused on that
I think he'd be a great coach for the
Chargers right now with a quarterback
but you got to put him in as a
ready-made winner um and I think he's
the kind of guy that maybe can take you
the next step he certainly was look four
years in in San Francisco three
Conference Championship games that won
Super Bowl he lost a Super Bowl on a
goal line stand he lost one Conference
Championship Game to the Giants at
overtime he lost another uh to Seattle
on a remarkable um pass breakup by uh
Richard Sherman uh you know famous pass
I mean he was as close as you're about
to get for that three-year stretch of
winning a Super Bowl um both those teams
I think went on to win it um so he he
was a remarkable NFL coach he's been a
remarkable college coach but he he's
going to move to his own his own beat
his own drummer all of that stuff you
can't expect him to be anything other
than Jim Harbaugh you got to buy the
whole package and hope it works out
great stuff Dan good to check with you
again thanks for joining us thanks Dan
that's Dan wetel Yahoo sports columnist
New York Times bestselling author